[Music]  [Music]  you don't think he relapsed ooh you know  what he's cheating on me are you sure  yeah well how do you know a girl knows  do you know with who no but maybe he's  with her I'm sure it's not I mean it god  I can't believe he's cheating on you  what the [ __ ]  viva la very absurd I've killed seven  people  torture them in unspeakable ways or  these sins I ask absolution  something has happened to my husband  he went to the store but he never came  home have you heard about this Gemini  killer no he always answers his phone  he'd find a widow that was an  interesting tattoo Gemini it's way  a very docile  difficult would it be to not gather to  take the NAMM would be a lot harder oh  yeah everything yes his name is Craig oh  it means just check again  right now you forgive us our trespasses  as we forgive those who have trespassed  against us sometimes what you see on the  outside not for what's on the inside I  smile all the time  they're doing bad things  you